AND GET OUR.
.
JUNE TWELFTH HEARING.
FOR THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE TODAY WE HAVE SIX
BILLS UP THREE OF WHICH ARE ON
CONSENT WE WILL ALLOW A WITNESS
ISN'T SUPPORT INTO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FOR EACH BILL. EACH
OF THESE WITNESSES SHOULD LIMIT
THEIR TESTIMONY TO TWO MINUTES
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES MAY ADD
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION BY
FEEDING ONLY THEIR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
AND HOW CAN WE CALL THE ARABS.
THAT WAS QUICKLY.
RUBIO. YOUR.
DOCTOR CHOI HERE.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
GRAY HAIRS.
STONE.
THURMOND HERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
WE HAVE QUITE.
CAN MISTER MONNING IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO COME UP.
WE HAVE ITEM ONE S. B. THREE
NINETY EIGHT BY MISTER MONNING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PERCENT
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY EIGHT.
IT EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE FOR
THE TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY
PROGRAM.
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
THE PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE THE TBI
PROGRAM PROVIDES GRANTS TO
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
CORDONING SERVICES. TO ASSISTED
DOUBTS WITH AN ACQUIRED
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY.
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
ADMINISTERS THE PROGRAM THEY'RE
CURRENTLY SEVEN TBI CENTER
PROVIDERS IN THE STATE.
A TBI PROGRAM MISTER THOUSANDS
OF TBI SURVIVORS AND ASSISTED
WITH THE REHABILITATION AND
INDEPENDENTLY LIVING.
IT HAS BEEN EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE
AND IT WORKS WITH VERY LIMITED
RESOURCES.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY EIGHT
EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE ANOTHER
FIVE YEARS. AND I WOULD ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
IN MADAM CHAIR WITH YOUR
PERMISSION I'D LIKE TO PERCENT.
A TWO WITNESSES KATIE SHINODA ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY. AND YVONNE ALLOW SURE
WHO USES TBI SERVICES THANK YOU
WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KATIE SHINODA.
I'M FROM MERCY GENERAL
HOSPITALS HOME AND COMMUNITY
REINTEGRATION PROGRAM FOR
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
I'M ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA SOCIAIS XIN A
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY THE SEVEN
DIFFERENT SITES THAT RECEIVED
OTHER GRANT FUNDING ADMINISTERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
MINING FORCE.
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AUTHORING
THIS BILL.
FOR THESE UP EXTREMELY VALUABLE
SERVICES I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
HEARING OUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
THAT THE THE TV I PROGRAM FOR
CALIFORNIA STARTED A LONG TIME
AGO NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AS A
DEMONSTRATION PRODUCT.
UP.
SORRY DEMONSTRATION PROGRAMS.
THE PROGRAMS OF IT STARTED WITH
ONLY FOUR FOUR SITES FOR THE
STATE IT EXPANDED TO SEVEN
DIFFERENT SITES IN TWO THOUSAND
AND THREE. AND.
THOUGH SPITE THOSE SITES HAVE
BEEN EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE AT OF
FAIRLY STE DADDY LET US STATE OF
FUNDING.
.
RECENTLY WE'VE HAD SOME FUNDING
CHALLENGES WITH THE THOUGH GRANT
AMOUNTS TO EACH SITE.
DECREASING TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND AND FOR NEXT YEAR
POTENTIALLY HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND PER SITE.
.
THE SITES HAVE BEEN VERY
FLEXIBLE WITH.
SHIFTING THEIR SERVICES TO STILL
BE EFFECTIVE FOR THEIR CONSUMERS.
THE PURPOSE OF SP THREE NINETY
EIGHT IS NOT TO ADDRESS THE
FUNDING CONCERNS IMMEDIATELY BUT
RATHER TO EXTEND THE PROGRAM FOR
FIVE YEARS.
TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS.
TO STRENGTHEN AND ESTABLISH LONG
TERM.
OUR PLANS FOR THESE VERY
IMPORTANT SERVICES.
DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURY IS NOT
GOING AWAY.
IN FACT THE INCIDENTS AND
RECOGNITION OF DRAMATIC BRAIN
INJURY IS INCREASING.
WITHOUT SPECIALIZEDPROGRAMS FOR
PEOPLE WITH TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY THEY OFTEN GO
MISUNDERSTOOD AND SOMETIMES
MISDIAGNOSED.
THE VARIABILITY IN THE
COMPLEXITY OF TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED.
PEOPLE LIVING WITH TBI. NEED
SUPPORTS OF SPECIALIST
THEY NEED ACCESS TO CASE
MANAGERS THERAPISTS.
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS SOCIAL
WORKERS COUNSELORS JOB COACHES
LIFE COACHES
PEOPLE WHO CAN UNDERSTAND
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY AND THE
IMPACT IT HAS ON PEOPLE'S LIVES.
HAVING TRAINED PROFESSIONALS
WORKING AS A TEAM TO UNDERSTAND
EACH PERSON'S INJURY THEIR
BACKGROUND AND THEIR PERSONAL
GOALS.
IT'S CRITICAL TO ITS SUCCESS.
THE SUPPORTS PROVIDED BY THIS
PROGRAM ARE PRICELESS AND CANNOT
BE REPLICATED.
SOME EXAMPLES OF THE SUPPORT
PROVIDED TO PEOPLE LIVING WITH
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
INCLUDE.
CASE MANAGEMENT INFORMATION AND
REFERRAL TRANSPORTATION
RESOURCES HOUSING RESOURCES.
VOCATIONAL EVALUATIONS AND
TRAINING JOB COACHING.
INDIVIDUALIZED COUNSELING FOR
PEOPLE WITH TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY AND THEIR FAMILIES.
DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURY EDUCATION
FOR PROFESSIONALS AND COMMUNITY
GROUPS.
COORDINATION BETWEEN SERVICE
PROVIDERS
ASSISTANCE WITH COMPLETING FORMS
TO APPLY FOR OTHER SOCIAL
SERVICES
MEDICAL INSURANCE GENERAL
ASSISTANCE OR HOUSING PROGRAMS.
SUPPORT GROUPS THAT OFFER
EDUCATION ACCEPTANCE
UNDERSTANDING AND COMMUNITY
REINTEGRATION.
DAY PROGRAMS THAT OFFER TBI
EDUCATION TRAINING AND
ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING.
AND RESPITE FOR CAREGIVERS.
THESE ARE SOME THINGS WE ARE
ALREADY DOING BUT THERE ARE MANY
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT DON'T
HAVE A TO BE AYE PROGRAM.
EACH PROGRAM HAS ITS OWN
SPECIFIC MODEL.
AND WE HELP TO. IMPROVE AND
EXPAND ON THOSE SERVICES.
.
THE INTENT OF THIS LEGISLATION
IS TO REALLY TO SERVE THE STATE.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
S. B. THREE NINETY EIGHT. THANK
YOU.
HOW MOTIONS SECOND?
THANK YOU.
ONLY A.
I WAS ON MY WAY TO WHERE I WAS
THAN THOSE SCHOOL TEACHER AND OF
OF SCHOOL. AND THEN.
OF THAT NO MONEY CERES HOOD DOWN
AND OUT OF THAT.
I WENT TO MAY MY FAIRS THAT
CENTER NINE TO BUSINESS TODAY.
AND THEN MAKE IT.
THE GUY WHO HIT ME WAS SPEED
THEN AND I DIED INSTANTLY.
DID THAT.
OKAY A MATHIS BRETT THEN TELL
THAT SAGE PAY HIM AND.
TELL THEM THE HEAD BACK. ON
RECORD AT IS DEAD THAT PACKS IN
THE. THREE MINUTES.
I LIVE DAY TEACH IN THOSE SCHOOL
KIDS IT BUT NOW I'VE. MORNINGTON.
EARLY CHILDHOOD TOO EARLY AND
THEN G. EVASION TISSUE THAN THAT
THAT THIS SAID THAT IT IS A BIT
TOO. WHEN THEY'RE YOUNG IT WILL
ONLY GO TO DAY ONE NINE.
I FILL HONORED TO BE ABLE HIM
PRIESTHOOD. THEY'LL ALL BE GONE
AND THAT IS SUPPOSED TO MEDI
DEFEND THAT STATUS WHICH NOW
INCLUDES.
THIS SAY ABOUT.
I AND THIS IS THE.
I HAVE CONDO BOOKS WITH HIM AND
WITH WHO AND.
I WOULD THEY TO.
SHARED THIS WITH UPDATES.
BUDGET AND THERE AND NOW
AND THEY THEY HIT.
I THEY TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCE
THAT MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE.
BUT THE PROGRESS OF MEDICAL
ADVANCEMENTS.
MANY PEOPLE SURVIVE DEAD THEY
OCCURRENCES.
NAY CAN.
DEVOTED THIS SAID THAT IT IS.
NO. AND I SHOULD SAY.
I WAS SO GOOD A TO THING MERCY
DON'T KNOW HIGHS WILL FOR ALL
THEIR HELP.
EIGHT THERAPIST BUT FOR A FISH
TO AND THAT IS TO GO BUT
PRACTICE AND THEN NEW HAS TO A
FLAT. TO EVERY INDIVIDUAL THEY
HELP.
I ASK
THEY ARE SO POOR AND S. B.. THEN
AND THE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HOW DO WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
IN DEPTH ROTH WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
HEARD SOME VERY COMPELLING
TESTIMONY SOME VERY POIGNANT
TESTIMONY.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ANGELA BLANCHARD ON
BEHALF OF REHAB WITHOUT WALLS
IT'S A DIVISION OF REST CARE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THINKS.
ON A ACTED WITH FREED CENTER FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING IN ONE OF THE
SEVEN TWO ADEQUATE ENTRY SITES
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU.
I'M VERY PLAY.
AN ATTORNEY FOR THIRTY YEARS
AND I'VE FOUGHT. AGAINST PEOPLE
WHO VOTE INJURIES AND. FOR MANY
YEARS. FOR THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY.
AND I'M ASHAMED TO SAY THAT BUT
THEM. I WAS SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE
THERE IS A TERM CALLED MILD.
DRAMATIC.
BRAIN INJURY MTP I.
AS OPPOSED TO SEVERE WINTER.
A.
KEPT TO GOTO WHEELCHAIR.
AND I MADE POO POO OVER THAT
SAYING DO NOT INJURED.
YOU CAN WALK YOU CAN TALK YOU
DON'T LOOK INJURED.
AND DOWN THE SAVED HIM LOT OF
MONEY.
THEN I WAS INJURED.
GOT RUN OVER BY EIGHTEEN WHEELER.
ANNA FOR CAR ACCIDENT ON THE
FREEWAY I'M SORRY I'M NERVOUS
BECAUSE. I HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
WORK FOR FOUR YEARS AND IF IT
WEREN'T.
FOR THIS PROGRAM.
AND THE M. TPI SUPPORT.
MEETINGS THAT WE ARE A.
GO TO.
I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO BE HERE
TODAY BECAUSE I CAN'T PRACTICE
ON OR SOMETHING. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON HENDRICK
INTERESTS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A BURKE BURNING
I'M THE TRAFFIC BRAIN INJURY
SPECIALIST AT FRIEDMAN AND THIS
IS ONE OF OUR CONSUMERS ALLEN
MORRIS AND HIS UNABLE TO SPEAK
AND HE'S ONE OF THE. PEOPLE THAT
WE GET TO PROVIDE LONG TERM
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO MORE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINE EIGHT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
HI I'M LISA DE ANGELO I AM A
DAUGHTER OF A SURVIVOR OF A
BRAIN INJURY I'M ALSO A SPEECH
PATHOLOGIST FOR THE LAST TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS. AND I'M A PROFESSOR
AT SEX STATE AND I DO MY
RESEARCH I HAVE DONE MY RESEARCH
FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS IN.
WORKING WITH PEOPLE TO BE AYE
AND MEMORY DEFICITS IN COGNITIVE
DEFICITS AND HELPING THEM GET
BACK TO LIFE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MATT HARLEEN IDEA AND
TWO YEARS AGO.
SUSTAINED A TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY.
AND.
I'VE ALTHOUGH IT YOU CAN'T TELL
BY LOOKING AT ME IT.
HAS IMPACTED MY LIFE
SIGNIFICANTLY.
AND I'D LIKE TO URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR S. B. THREE NINETY
EIGHT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BART
WILCOX AND I WORK IN THE SUPPORT
GROUP CALLED BRIDGES AT MERCY
OUTPATIENT REHAB CENTER. AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORTING OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MIKE MODE AND I'M
ANOTHER TV AYE SURVIVOR AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL THANK. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THERESA ANDERSON
ON BEHALF OF THE ARCANE UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CAROUSEL
AND I'M A TWO TIME TBI SURVIVOR
AND A REGISTERED NURSE I'M
ASKING. FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRIS SIR SIR AND I'M
AND TBS SURVIVORS ON US FOR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M DIANE ANDERSON I AM THE
PARENT AND CARE GIVER OF THE TV
I.
VICTIM ANDA I STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I'M MY NAME'S MARK ANDERSON AND
THAT WAS MY MOTHER AND.
.
MY SON WAS THROUGH ENOUGH YEARS.
AGO. A MAN TEXTING SLAMMED INTO
ME GOING OVER FIFTY MILES AN
HOUR AND I LOST MY CAREER.
THIS ONE IS UP FORTY THREE CELLS
ARE OPTIONAL WORLD FOR UPS AND I
CAN'T FUNCTION DO ANYTHING LIKE
THAT ANYMORE.
AND NOW MY EIGHTY YEAR OLD
MOTHER HAS TO LOOK AFTER ME.
AND I'M FIFTY FOUR AND I DON'T
KNOW.
I'M VERY UNSURE ABOUT THE FUTURE
AND A. GENIUS FOR GROUP AND
KATIE'S GROUP AND.
.
THE GROUP AT SAKS STATES AND
EVERYTHING'S BEEN A TREMENDOUS
SUPPORT ESPECIALLY. WITH THE
ISOLATION THAT FOR. ALL OF US
HAVE HAD TO SUFFER THROUGH.
AND SO PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M DOCTOR COUNTY MARTINEZ
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
HEAD TRAUMA SUPPORT PROJECT OF
SACRAMENTO. AND I FACILITATE THE
MULTI BE AYE SUPPORT GROUP FOR
FOLKS IN THERE ABOUT SIX OF
THOSE FOLKS HERE YOU PARTY MATT.
I'VE ALSO SPENT THE LAST TEN
YEARS WORKING WITH DOCTOR STEVEN
OR PASKIN SACRAMENTO AND. MANY
MANY OF OUR PATIENTS HAVE
DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURY.
AND ON BEHALF OF ALL THOSE
FOLKS.
.
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL ABERNATHY
SUSTAIN THIS DRAMATIC.
TWO THOUSAND OR.
AS.
I STROKES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I'M ROBERT KLEIN.
INJURY IN TWO THOUSAND AND.
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY WHETHER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PIMCO'S. UP.
SINA OF WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE WITH
MONNING THINK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS TONIGHT I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENDATION OF THE
WITNESSES WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES SO I'M SORRY MISS
RUNNING OUT RIGHT IN A BRING IT
TO THE GUYS I APOLOGIZE. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THAT FROM.
BUT COMMITTEE.
MORE OF A COMMENT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COURAGE IN
COMING HERE AND SHARING YOUR
PERSONAL STORY AND. THOSE OF THE
ROSTER OF WHO HAVE STEPPED UP
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES WE HEAR ABOUT
THINGS AND IT'S A NON TO WE
SHOULD THE FACE.
THAT'S WHEN WE KNOW WE'VE GOT TO
TAKE CARE OF THIS PROBLEM CENTER
MONNING THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I ALSO
THINK THE AUTHORED AN ALL THAT
GETS ONLY THANK YOU FOR BEING
SUCH A GREAT WITNESS.
AND FOR THE WORK YOU'RE DOING
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN TO HELP
CHILDREN UNDERSTAND DIFFERENCE
AND.
.
AND THAT WHILE MANY OF US MAY BE
DIFFERENT THAT WE ALL ARE
CAPABLE OF LIVING IN THE PENDANT
LEE AND SO. I DON'T THINK YOU
FOR YOUR GREAT TESTIMONY AND FOR
USING YOUR EXPERIENCES TO HELP
YOUNG PEOPLE AND OTHERS THING
AND THANK ALL OF THOSE WHO SPOKE
TODAY AND ALL THOSE WHO
EXPERIENCE. TOO MANY BRAIN
INJURY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ADVOCACY AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANYONE.
OKAY.
THIS MORNING I MAKE THOSE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN AGAIN THANK
YOU MEMBERS AND FOR YOUR
COMMENTS.
A. I WOULD LIKE TO SUFFER BRIEF
CLOSE WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY
I CARRIED ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
NINETY EIGHT THE SAME NUMBER.
WHICH.
TRANSFERRED.
TBI SUPPORT SERVICES FOR MENTAL
HEALTH.
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION.
AS YOU ALL KNOW A TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY IS NOT A MENTAL
ILLNESS OR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE.
IT IS A BODY HELPED ISSUE AND
RESULTS FROM TRAUMA TO THE BRAIN.
WELL WE ONLY HAVE EIGHT CENTERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF THEM ARE IN RURAL AREAS
SUPPORT IN SOME CASES ACCIDENT
VICTIMS BUT IN SOME CASES
VETERANS WHO GET PRIMARY CARE
THROUGH VETERANS ADMINISTRATION.
BUT TO RETURN TO HOMES AND HOME
COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES.
THE TBI CENTERS HAVE ALSO
SUPPORTED. A. VETERANS WHO'VE
SUFFERED FROM TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY. AS THE WITNESSES RAISED.
WE'RE GOING FROM VERY LOW
FUNDING OF ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND YEAR PERCENTER T.
EVEN LOWER FUNDING. THIS BILL IS
NOT ABOUT THE FUNDING BUT I
MENTION IT BECAUSE I HOPE WE CAN
pBUDGET CYCLES
TO ARM MAKE SURE IT'S ONE OF THE
BEST INVESTMENTS I BELIEVE WE'RE
MAKING IS A STATE.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY IS TO
EXTEND THE SUNSET.
WOULD BE OUR HOPE TO REMOVE THE
SUNSET AT SOME POINT BUT WERE
SEEKING A FIVE YEAR EXTENSION.
AND WOOD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND AND.
IT DOES HAVE A DO PASS A TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CAN HOLLOW BILL PLEASE.
RUBIO CRANKED RUBIO AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE I'M GONNA.
RAMBLE I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I AFFAIRS.
THIS AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE THE BILL THE SEVEN
ZERO.
THANK YOU THE BILL'S OUT SEVEN
ZERO AND THEN.
WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR AN
ARTICLE WE DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THANK YOUR HAVE MOTION AND
SECOND CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
I HAVE.
S. B. NINE TWENTY FIVE BELL.
SB TEN FORTY LEYVA AND S. B.
TWELVE SEVENTY FOUR MCGUIRE.
NO NO THERE'S ONE OF CONSENT AND
ONE.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DARTED CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HI MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE PRAYERS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE. STONE AYE
THURMOND. THURMOND AYE THE BILL.
JUMP SHIP RICHARD OTHER.
THANK YOU.
TYLER POINT OF CLARIFICATION SP
TEN FORTY S. BY SENATOR DODD OUR
THAT'S UNLESS.
YEAH SO I WAS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND.
SENATOR LEAVE OUT WILL NOT BE
PRESENTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES WILL BE
PRESENTING ON HER BEHALF.
SO WE HAVE A SB ELEVEN SEVEN.
AND YOU'RE WELCOME THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
SP ELEVEN OH SEVEN WOULD ALLOW
ANY NONPROFIT OR FOR PROFIT
AGENCY TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
VENDOR IS A XIN PROCESS THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
SO THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE FAMILY
HOME AGENCY SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA HAS RIGHTFULLY
PRIORITIZE PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ADULTS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO
LIVE WITH FAMILIES AND RECEIVE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT IN A FAMILY
SETTING.
EVERY FAMILY SHOULD HAVE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO CHOOSE THE CARE AND
RESOURCE IS A BEST FIT THEIR
NEEDS AND FINANCIAL SITUATIONS.
FOR SOME OF THE FAMILY HOME
MODEL OFFERS A LESS RESTRICTIVE
ALTERNATIVE TO GROUP CALLED AN
INTERMEDIATE.
CARE FACILITY CARE OF FACILITY
SETTINGS THE FAMILY HOME
PROVIDER OFFERS MORE THAN JUST
THE BASIC NECESSITIES OF FOOD
AND SHELTER THEY ALSO HELP THE
INDIVIDUAL THE GROOMING. HYGIENE
SCHEDULING TRANSPORTATION FOR
APPOINTMENTS AND SUPPORT FOR
THEIR ACTIVITIES SUCH AS SCHOOL
WORK AND RECREATION.
THESE PROVIDERS ALSO TEACH LIFE
SKILLS BASED ON THE NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL WITHIN THE HOME
SETTING.
IN CALIFORNIA BOTH NONPROFIT AND
FOR PROFIT COMPANIES PROVIDE
MEDICAL WAIVERS AND INTERMEDIATE
CARE FAMILY SERVICES
BUT WE CURRENTLY LIMIT MEDI CAL
FAMILY HOME AGENCY SERVICES. TO
ONLY NONPROFIT AGENCIES WHICH
GREATLY AFFECTS THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT FAMILIES HAVE WHICH USING
CARE AND RESOURCES FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES.
BY ALLOWING ANY NONPROFIT OR FOR
PROFIT AGENCY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE VENDOR REZAEI XIN.
PROCESS SB ELEVEN OO SEVEN WILL
INCREASE THE OPPORTUNITY OF
FLEXIBILITY FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES TO LIVE IN A FAMILY
SETTING.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO MENTION
THAT THIS BILL WILL NOT CHANGE
THE QUALIFICATION FOR PROVIDERS
MEANING THAT BOTH FOR PROFIT AND
NON PROFITS WOULD HAVE THE SAME
STANDARDS OVERSIGHT AND CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
HERE IT SUPPORT I HAVE ROBERT.
ALRIGHT EXTENDING ALLEN.
ALLEN OR PROPERTY FROM SGI YOU
CALIFORNIA. AND MICHELLE MY NOSE
FROM ROSE CARE INCORPORATED.
THANK YOU.
HILL
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHELLE
MINA'S AND I AM VICE PRESIDENT
OF REST CARE. AND A CO SPONSOR
OF A S. B. ELEVEN ZERO SEVEN.
READ CARE IS THE NATION'S
LARGEST PROVIDER PRIVATE
PROVIDER OF SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
WE SUCCESSFULLY OPERATE FAMILY
HOME AGENCIES IN THIRTEEN OTHER
STATES OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE FAMILY HOME AGENCY MODEL
OFFERS THE CHOICE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR ADULTS WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO
RESIDE IN NURTURING AND DIVERSE
THE FAMILY HOME SETTINGS. WITH
FAMILY HOME PROVIDERS WHO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE SUPPORT AND
DALY ASSISTANCE AS DETERMINED BY
THE INDIVIDUALS PROGRAM PLAN.
THIS MODEL EMBRACES AND PROMOTES
COMMUNITY INCLUSION.
AND IT'S FLEXIBILITY OFFERS
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAXIMIZE
INDEPENDENCE FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS.
THE AGENCY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
RECRUITING.
SELECT DEAN PREPARING AND
MONITORING THE FAMILY HOME
PROVIDERS.
CALIFORNIA HAS PLACED A HIGH
PRIORITY ON BRINGING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS.
IN TO LIVE IN IN AND IN DOWN WE
HOPE AGENCIES SETTINGS ANNA SB
ELEVEN ZERO SEVEN WOULD ALLOW
FOR EQUAL TREATMENT.
FOR NOT FOR PROFIT AND FOR
PROFIT PROVIDERS WHO CHOOSE TO
PROVIDE LESS RESTRICTIVE MODELS
AND SERVICES. IN THIS FAMILY
ENVIRONMENT.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THOSE AND I AM AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MEMBERS I MY NAME IS
ELEANOR PADDY AND WORK WITH THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION AND OUT WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT WE WORK IN CONJUNCTION
WITH LESS CARE WE REPRESENT.
REST CARE WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
AND RESIDENTIAL SERVICES AS WELL
AS HOME CARE SERVICES AND. OUR
MEMBERS ARE INTERESTED IN AT CA
YOU HAS BEEN ON RECORD IN
SUPPORT OF THE FULL RANGE OF
COMMUNITY SETTINGS AND THEN
HAVING. INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES HAVE ABOUT THE FULL
RANGE OF SERVICES AVAILABLE
RIGHT NOW I'M OUR MEMBERS WORK
WITH. A BREAST CARE CONSUMERS.
AND IF THOSE CONSUMERS WERE TO
MOVE TO A FAMILY EMERGENCY AND
VIRTUALLY THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO STAY WITH THOSE CONSUMERS AND.
WE FIND THAT UNFORTUNATE AND
WE'D LIKE THEM TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT KIND OF CONTINUITY OF
CARE SHOULD THE OPTION BECOME
AVAILABLE FOR FAMILY HOME AGENCY.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE JOINED
TOGETHER WITH PRESS CARE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I IS THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
HEARING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTIO AND A
SECOND WHICH LIKE CLOSED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE.
THANK YOU.
SO IT BUT WE DO HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION TO PASS.
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR ATTACKING
GLOBAL PLEASE
RUBIO I'VE RUBIO AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I DAIS.
THERE'S AYE STONE
STONE AYE THURMOND.
ZERO.
WE HAVE SIX ZERO GOES ON TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND WILL THE
FEDERAL OPEN FOR. ADAMS THANK
YOU THANK
.
THANK YOU WILL HOLD.
NO MORE WAITING FOR SENATOR BELL.
AGO HAVE IF THE CALL FROM
MISTER A.
THURMOND
FOR S. B.. ELEVEN SEVEN.
S. B. ELEVEN OH SEVEN BY CENTER
LEYVA.
DO PASSED ASSEMBLY FLOOR
THURMOND.
THURMOND I.
SIMPLY TO QUE THAT BILL GOT OUT
SEVEN ZERO TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
OR THIS. WHILE AWAITING MY
DAUGHTER NADIA'S HERE SHISA
SHADOWING ME ALL DAY TODAY
WAGNER.
MY TEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER.
AND SHE HAS BETTER QUESTIONS AND
SOME OF YOU GUYS DO NOT HAVE.
AND YET SHE IS SHE'S SHE'S
REALLY LIKE THIS RIGHT NADIA.
TRAINING AND TRAINING.
RIGHT THERE YOU GO THERE YOU GO
WELCOME CENTERVILLE.
THE BILL.
SECOND.
IT.
THE PATH OF A.
WHAT OF THEM THANK YOU?
?
APPRECIATE.
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THE S. R..
YES THEY ARE ONE OF SEVEN SET
LEGACY HOME RESOLUTION.
IT BASICALLY IS THE CLAIRE OF.
.
THE IDEA THAT.
LEGACY HOME URGING REGIONAL
CENTERS.
.
TWO AND OTHER AGENCIES TO BRING
HOME AWARENESS TO THIS LEGACY
HOMES PROGRAM.
IT ALLOWS FAMILIES
TO DONATE HOME CONDO OR OTHER
SUCH GLOWING. TO EXPERIENCE
NONPROFIT.
ORGANIZATION.
WHOSE MISSION IS TO SERVE PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES.
AND.
.
IF YOU'RE A PARENT THAT SOMEBODY
WITH A DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY.
LET ME.
HAS SEVERE DISABILITIES.
YOU ARE ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT
THEIR.
FUTURE.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
AND NOT HAVING OF HAVING.
THAT WORRY ALWAYS ON YOUR MIND.
I HAVING SOME PROGRAM WHERE YOU
CAN DONATE IF YOU HAVE ASSETS
THE ONLY US YOU MIGHT HAVE WOULD
BE YOUR HOME.
IT MIGHT BE THE ONLY THING YOU
GOT.
IT MIGHT BE THE ONE THING THAT
WILL KEEP YOUR CHILD.
IT'S HAVE A HAPPY LIFE ONCE YOU
MOVE ON.
AND PASS ON SO I THINK THIS
RESOLUTION IS TO.
.
LET PEOPLE LIKE MY FAMILY AND
OTHERS THAT HAVE.
FAMILY MEMBERS THEIR
DEVELOPMENTAL. WOULD DEVELOP
DISABILITIES TO HAVE. AN
OPPORTUNITY AND SUPPORT.
THESE GUYS A PROGRAM SO THAT'S
THAT'S RESOLUTION I HOPE WE CAN.
ALL PARTICIPATE IN OUR OWN WAY
SUPPORTING AND PUBLICIZING.
CALIFORNIA LEGACY HOMES PROGRAM
THANK YOU.
HELLO AND MY NAME IS PATTY UP
LINGER AND I REPRESENT THE
LETTERMAN HOUSING ALLIANCE WERE
MADE UP OF WHERE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ORGANIZATION MADE UP OF
SEVERAL. HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WORK WITH PEOPLE
FOR WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THIS
BOOK HERE IS. PUT OUT BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED LITTON
NETWORK AND IT HAS STORIES OF
SEVERAL LUCKY PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO LIVE IN THEIR OWN
HOMES. AND WITH WITH SUPPORT AND
THE LACK OF HOUSING I CAN'T SAY
IT ENOUGH THERE'S A LACK OF
HOUSING IN PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES MOST OF THEM OVER
EIGHTY OR. EIGHTY PERCENT AT
LEAST EIGHTY PERCENT ARE ON
SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY INCOME
NINE HUNDRED AND TEN DOLLARS A
MONTH IF ANYONE'S CHECK RENTS
LATELY OR THE HOUSING SITUATION
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S
IT'S TREMENDOUS AND PEOPLE
CANNOT LIVE IN THEIR OWN HOME
UNLESS THEY HAVE SOME SORT OF
SUBSIDY IN WE THIS PROGRAM HERE
IS IT LEAVING A HOLE. IN IN
PERPETUITY FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WHO A
FAMILY THAT HAS A CHILD WITH A
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY THEY
CAN DONATE THIS HOME TO A
HOUSING ORGANIZATION NONPROFIT.
THAT WILL KEEP THEIR HOME FOR
THE CHILD AND PROVIDE THEIR
SUPPORT ENOUGH THAT HOME IS NO
LONGER APPROPRIATE FOR THE CHILD
THEN THE MONEY CAN FOLLOW THE
CHILDHOOD WHATEVER IS IMPORTANT
SO WE HAVE A LACK OF HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS MODEL IS GOING
TO CREATE MORE HOUSING OPTIONS
FOR OTHERS BECAUSE THAT ONE
PERSON WITH A DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY MAY HAVE OTHERS WITH
A DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY AS
WELL TO LIVE IN THIS HOME. AND
IT'S AN OPTION WHERE THEY CAN
LIVE AFFORDABLY AND LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND I THINK THAT
REGARDLESS OF THE DESIRES OF
PEOPLE TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY IN
ACCESS SAFE AND STABLE. LONG
TERM HOUSING AFTER THEIR PARENTS
ARE KNOWING NO LONGER ABLE TO
CARE FOR HOME WITH THE CURRENT
REAL ESTATE MARKET IT'S HARD TO
FIND SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN
AFFORD TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU AYE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND THE DESTRUCTIVE VACATION ARE
YOU ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TERESA ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
RQ CP IN SUPPORT OR.
THANK YOU. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
OKAY.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST THAT THE WE ALREADY STARTED.
WAS IN THIS AND WE NOW HAVE.
JUST ONE POINT OUT THAT.
HOUSING CONSORTIUM OF EAST BAY
ALUM ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA
COUNTIES HAS.
ACCEPTED A LEGACY HOA.
SO A YOU WILL HAVE.
THE START THERE. AND.
NORTH BAY HOUSING NAPA SOLANO
SONOMA COUNTIES HAS
THE ASSUME HOOKED UP OTHER PARTS
OF CALIFORNIA. PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROGRAM AND.
HOPE IT SPREADS LIKE WILDFIRE
OUT OF.
I THINK YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS STOPPED IS MEANT
IT THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR YES THE
MOTION IS TO BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE DUCKED OUT
RUBIO AYE.
DOCTOR CHOI.
ARAMBULA THE NUMBER NINE
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN I
ADVANCED.
BEARS ARE STILL. STONE AYE
THURMOND.
THURMOND I.
SEVEN ZERO OKAY CHO OF. THANK
YOU WELL IT'S. PAST SEVEN ZERO
TO THESE UP ASSEMBLY FLOOR THAT
IF.
OKAY WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU